let's do some equations that deal with
absolute values and just as a bit of a
review when you take the absolute value
of a number let's say I take the
absolute value of negative 1 what you're
really doing is you're saying how far is
that number from zero and in the case of
negative 1 if we draw a number line
right there that's a very badly drawn
number line so if we draw a number line
right there that's zero you have a
negative 1 right there well it's one
away from zero so the absolute value of
negative one is 1 and the absolute value
of 1 is also it's also one away from
zero it's also equal to 1 so on some
level absolute values you know it's the
distance from zero but another I guess
simpler way to think of it it always
results in the positive version of the
number the absolute value the absolute
value of negative seven thousand three
hundred and forty six is equal to seven
thousand three hundred and forty six so
with that in mind let's try to solve
some equations with an app with absolute
values in them so let's say add the
equation the absolute value of X minus
five is equal to ten and one way you can
interpret this and I want you to think
about this this is actually saying that
the distance between X and five is equal
to ten so how many numbers that are
exactly 10 away from five and you can
already think of the solution to this
equation but I'll show you how to solve
it systematically now this is going to
be true in two of two situations either
X minus 5 is equal to positive 10 right
if this evaluates out to positive 10
that when you take the absolute value of
it you're going to get positive 10 or or
X minus 5 might evaluate to negative 10
if X minus 5 evaluated to negative 10
when you take the absolute value of it
you would get 10 again so X minus 5
could also be equal to negative 10 both
of these would satisfy this equation now
to solve this one add five to both sides
of this equation you get X is
2:15 to solve this one add five to both
sides of this equation X is equal to
negative five so our solution there's
two X's that satisfy this equation X
could be 15 15 minus 5 is 10 take the
absolute value you're going to get 10 or
X could be negative 5 negative 5 minus 5
is negative 10 take the absolute value
you get 10 and notice both of these
numbers are exactly 10 away from the
number 5 let's do another one of these
let's do another one let's say we have
the absolute value of X plus 2 is equal
to 6 so what does that tell us that
tells us that either X plus 2 that the
thing inside the absolute value sign is
equal to 6 or the thing inside of the
absolute value sign the X plus 2 could
also be negative 6 right if this whole
thing evaluated negative 6 you take the
absolute value you would get 6 so or X
plus 2 could equal negative 6 and then
if you subtract 2 from both sides of
this equation you get X could be equal
to 4 if you subtract 2 from both sides
of this equation you get X could be
equal to negative 8 so these are the two
solutions to the equation and just to
kind of have it gel in your mind that
absolute value you can kind of view it
as a distance you could rewrite this
problem as the absolute value of x minus
negative 2 is equal to 6 and so this is
telling you this is asking me what are
the X's that are exactly 6 away from
negative 2 remember up here we said what
are the X's that are exactly 10 away
from positive 5 right whatever number
you're subtracting from positive 5 these
are both 10 away from positive 5 this is
asking what is exactly 6 away from
negative 2 and it's going to be 4 or
negative 8 you could try those numbers
out for yourself let's do another one of
these let's do another one and we'll do
it in purple
let's say we have the absolute value of
4x I'm going to change this problem up a
little bit 4x minus 1 the absolute value
of 4x minus 1 is equal to actually this
cube is equal to 19 so just like the
last few problems 4x minus 1 could be
equal to 19 for X minus 1 could be equal
to 19 or 4x minus 1 might evaluate to
negative 19 because then we take the
absolute value you're going to get 19
again or 4x minus 1 could be equal to
negative 19 then you just solve these
two equations add 1 to both sides of
this equation we can do them
simultaneously even add 1 to both sides
of this you get 4x is equal to 20 add 1
to both sides of this equation you get
4x is equal to negative 18 divide both
sides of this by 4 you get X is equal to
5 divide both sides of this by 4 you get
X is equal to negative 18 over 4 which
is equal to negative negative 9 halves
so these both of these X values satisfy
the equation try it out negative 9
halves times 4 this will become a
negative 18 negative 18 minus 1 is
negative 19 take the absolute value you
get 19 you put a 5 here 4 times 5 is 20
minus 1 is positive 19 so you take the
absolute value once again you'll get a
19 let's try to graph one of these just
for fun so let's say I have let's say I
have y is equal to the absolute value of
x plus 3 so this is a function or a
graph with an absolute value in it so
let's think about two scenarios there's
one scenario where the thing inside of
the absolute value is positive so you
have the scenario where X plus 3 I'll
write it over here X plus 3 is greater
than 0 and then you have the scenario
where X plus 3 is less than 0 right what
X plus 3 is greater than 0 this graph or
this line or I guess we can't call it a
line this function is the same thing as
Y is equal to X plus three right if this
thing over here is greater than zero
then the absolute value sign is
irrelevant so then this thing is the
same thing as Y is equal to X plus three
but when is X plus 3 greater than zero
well if you subtract 3 from both sides
you get X is greater than negative 3 so
when X is greater than negative 3 this
graph is going to look just like Y is
equal to X plus 3 now when X plus 3 is
less than 0
in the situation where this the inside
of our absolute value sign is negative
in that situation this equation is going
to be y is equal to the negative the
negative of X plus 3 how can I say that
well look if this is going to be a
negative number if X plus 3 is going to
be a negative number right that's what
we're assuming here if it's going to be
a negative number then when you take the
absolute value of a negative number
you're going to make it positive that's
just like multiplying it by negative 1
well if you're if you know you're taking
the absolute value of a negative number
it's just like multiplying it by
negative 1 because you're going to make
it positive and this is going to be the
situation this is the X plus 3 is less
than 0 if we subtract 3 from both sides
when X is less than negative 3 so when X
is less than negative 3 the graph will
look like this when X is greater than
negative 3 the graph will look like that
so let's see what that will make the
entire graph look like
let me draw let me draw my axes that's
my x-axis
that's my y-axis so just to let me
multiply this out just so that we have
it in MX plus B form so this is equal to
negative X minus 3 negative X minus 3 so
let's just figure out what this graph
would look like in general negative X
minus 3 negative X minus 3 the
y-intercept is negative 3 so 1 2 3 and
negative x means it goes it slopes
downward has a downward slope of 1 so
look like this it would look like this
the x-intercept the x-intercept would be
at X is equal to so if you say y is
equal to zero that would happen that
would happen when X is equal to negative
three so it's going to go through that
line that point right there and the
graph if we didn't have this constraint
right here would look something like
this it would look something like that
that's if we didn't constrain it to a
certain interval on the x-axis now this
graph what does it look like let's see
it has this y-intercept at positive 3
positive 3 just like that and where's
its x-intercept when Y is equal to 0 X
is negative 3 so it also goes to that
point right there and has a slope of 1
so it would look something like this
that's what this graph looks like now
what we figured out is that this
absolute value function it looks like
this purple graph when X is less than
negative 3 so when X is less than
negative 3 that's X is equal to negative
3 right there
when X is less than negative 3 it looks
like this purple graph right there so
that's when X is less than negative 3
but when X is greater than negative 3 it
looks like the green graph it looks like
that
so this graph looks like the strange V
when X is greater than negative 3 this
is positive so we have the graph of we
have a positive slope but then when X is
less than negative 3 we're essentially
taking the negative of the function if
you want to view it that way and so we
have this negative slope so you kind of
have this v-shaped
function this v-shaped graph which is
indicative of an absolute value function